NBC Sports Group coverage of the Stanley
Cup final continues tomorrow night and
document will be on the call and doc
joins us now how's the voice doc great
it's it's I'm resting it out but it's
just outstanding it's inspired by what I
get to watch it's just magnificent I was
worried for you with the voice you know
just the first period of Game one and
then the last minute or so of Game two
you know you got to pace yourself Duncan
if that's it if this goes seven I'm
worried about that voice thank you I
appreciate your concern in there it's
been one of those Springs where I've had
to go to the roids a little bit Oh
sometimes we do strain a little bit and
so that means that I can reach out and
maybe pull an outside pitch down the
third-base line with a little extra
power so what what we've learned so far
is doc Emmerich is on
performance-enhancing drugs doc I don't
know if you can be suspended but I'm
glad that you know you've you've a
you've got out in front of this doc
Emmerich is on steroids can you imagine
[Laughter]
Wow okay what is your official height
and weight doc it goes at 5-7 166 it
probably should be 160 but right now
it's 166 well you want to put on some
grounds for the postseason yeah I gotta
take some off you're absolutely right
how do you explain elbowing under the
basket and we do have a practice court
man in DC and pjo she has a really nice
outside shot he and a couple of guys go
down and and last year they were playing
horse you know that old outside game
that you used to do trick shots yeah and
now they just practice outside shots
around the 3-point circle and TJ's got a
really nice shot I go down and watch
them every once in a while they do that
just as some guys play soccer before
games and the caps have that court
nearby that that is used by the
mystics and wizards and it's pretty
decent how is your shot awful
I learned unfortunately in the archaic
days because I'm archaic to shoot foul
shots like Olli did in Hoosiers under
hat we've talked about this before and
so I think you've granted me at least
five free throws underhand sometime in
the future yes at a date to be
determined yes and I'm sure that there
will be a tremendous viewer decline so
we have we have to wait until you're
actually doing shows that don't matter
and I don't think that ever happens what
what we were expectations going into
this series and after two games did they
live up to those expectations
expectations were that it would be heavy
for check on the part of the Vegas
nights that would mean for those of you
watch basketball that would be like a
full-court press the entire game and
that's kind of the way it's happened
with both teams both teams have been
able to apply it I didn't expect that as
much and I sure didn't expect
straight-ahead hockey for all 60 minutes
and the kind of nail-biting hockey that
would send somebody to steroids
wonderful hockey and I'm anticipating
that we're going to have at least six
games of it is just thrilling to watch
and it may not be the best analogy but I
thought last game out loud that it's
like being one of those nails inside a
pinball machine where it's happening so
quickly around you that it's
mind-boggling and I think that's the way
it's been to the players to berry trots
the coach of the Capitals told us that
one of the replays that he showed the
team from the first game was where there
were five quick puck possession changes
and there were five different players
flat on the ice at the same time it was
that wacky and that's kind of the way
this is gone
but it sure is fun to watch out that the
coaches like it because they like to see
things more under control but it's just
been wonderful to watch you stock
emmerich the NHL play by play voice or
NBC tomorrow night at 8:00 Eastern
Series now shifting to Washington DC
what do you do in between periods
usually wind up chatting with Eddie
Olczyk and learning lots more things
about horses and and hockey I will talk
over things that we've seen and he'll
also talk over such interesting items as
I did ask him what you know because we
were in Las Vegas what percentage of the
crowd that he thought might have some
interest in the game beyond just fans
and he thought over half hmm what do you
think of gambling with uh with the NHL
doc I don't well with the NHL I I defer
to the commissioner who said that it was
too early to have any kind of to have
any kind of opinion on it because you
have to kind of let the smoke clear and
see how it's going to sort out with the
NHL that I guess is the opinion that I
have I I don't really get the full grasp
of it because I'm not a gambler and I
haven't studied it well enough to have
an opinion I am concerned when I when I
read some articles as it today about how
it might have effect on secondary
schools and the athletes who play in
secondary schools and I did see an
article to that effect today
I don't know how widespread this is
going to become and I I just AM
concerned how it might affect the
athletes I know that your job is
play-by-play of telling us what you're
seeing but can you try to get ahead of
yourself with with Holt B's save you
know you're calling it in real time but
is there a part of you that you're
anticipating something or can that take
you into an area that's dangerous as a
play-by-play man it probably can take
you to dangerous area but by the same
token when you one of the things that
you draw on is 45 years of doing this
and having seen other saves that are
similar you know Tim Thomas made a stop
in the Tampa Bay Boston series that
spurred Boston on to win that and go on
to the championship round here we are in
the second game of a Stanley Cup final
Frank Peter Angelo made a stop on Peter
Stastny
in a series between Pittsburgh and New
Jersey and all of these things that that
you write
through time and you think is this going
to be one that's going to be gone back
to I think the the ultimate one for me
was the one that mark Andres Larry made
in the last second and a half of Game
seven of a Stanley Cup final that
prevented Detroit from taking the game
into overtime and maybe winning it at
home and maybe Pittsburgh doesn't get a
championship in 2009 so those are all
things that flash through your mind but
after a save like that if they win the
game if if then Vegas doesn't pull the
goaltender and tie the game up if they
win the game then that's when it starts
to sink in that this might be something
that would cause momentum to shift but
the coach of Washington berry trots has
been very careful to say every game is a
reset don't rush to judgment about
things like this but that's what coaches
say broadcasters have a little more
flexibility and that thing is gonna be
very big to overcome but it could happen
as soon as Game three of Vegas wins with
the possibility of another expansion
team in Seattle with the success of
Vegas can you see any modifications of
building another expansion team based
off of aigis having this much success
well Vegas paid 500 million and so the
price is going to go up and the
expectation that a team is going to have
for that price is the same set of rules
at least for their expansion draft the
pressure that team is going to have is
they're going to have to make as good at
decisions as Vegas did and that is going
to be ultimate pressure and there's
going to be pressure on existing teams
there are 12 teams including Washington
out of the 31 that have never won a
Stanley Cup before there are four teams
that have never that have never been to
a Stanley Cup final before and they've
been in business a long time you imagine
how the people in st. Louis feel sorry
to mention them but the last time they
were was when Bobby Orr flew through the
air in 1970 that was the last time their
team got to a final they haven't won a
championship so there's a certain amount
of envy of what's going on in Vegas
right now
but it is it's all a fantastic thing
that has just snowballed and gone on
because of the excellence of the players
and that's the main thing that we always
try to keep in mind that it's not
certainly about us but it's about a
glorious story that's been written there
and maybe they'll win maybe they won't
but it won't change the the ultimate
fact that they've had a wonderful year
for their first year out doc I was gonna
keep you ten minutes at the most and
it's ten minutes in 15 seconds so I want
to be a man of my word and I want you to
be able to relax I want you to go back
to your steroids and I want you to have
a great day off oh thank you I look
forward to practicing my final shots in
Washington and one of these days I'll
get to see you on the course I love that
Thank You doc the great doc Hemmer
NHL play by play voice you could tell
that voice is that's a that's postseason
form there four more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show ass
[Music]